this is it folks the last episode and
gamespot's week-long series highlighting
steam early access games I'm Chris
waters and for the past four episodes
I've been your host as gamespot staff
from around the globe have highlighted
these games that are still in
development yet available to purchase
and play we've got a whole new group of
games for you today so why am I even
still talking now given all the games
we've covered in this series so far I'm
surprised it's taken us this long to
find something as punny as cannon brawl
get it cuz like cannonball only pin a
bra
kennen brawl is an action RTS game that
begins with your evil uncle trying to
take over your father's Empire and it's
your duty to protect the kingdom as an
airship commander you are tasked with
mining precious minerals to purchase
cannons shields bombs and sweet sweet
lasers to destroy your opponent's castle
victories in the campaign mode can
unlock new weapons and defenses you can
use against the AI or other humans in
multiplayer mode before battle you get
to look at your upcoming terrain and
choose a pilot that comes with an added
bonus like reduced cool times as well as
five different items to use against your
opponent each item can be upgraded in
battle in exchange for goals and offer
necessary benefits including stronger
force fields longer distance for rockets
and more powerful sweet sweet lasers the
destructible terrain can come into play
strategically and the campaign guides
you on how to effectively use various
items to the best of your ability can't
get to your opponents cannons shoot them
from below and watch them smash to the
ground from the high intensity strategic
combat to the light-hearted cartoony
style to the dynamic battle music
there's a lot to love about cannon brawl
and although there might be some
tweaking in order cannon brawl feels in
many ways complete whether you're
unlocking pilots and items in the
campaign mode or going head-to-head in a
battle online kennen brawl is a blast
if there was ever a game to make you
really want to Don a tweed jacket and a
top hat and go roam the Scottish Moors
it would be this next one because in it
that's what the murderous robots do and
who doesn't like to model their life
choices based off of murderous robots
here's Kevin van org with sir you are
being hunted survival games seem all the
rage and many of them feature zombies
and the such zombies may be ugly and
frightening but you know what they
aren't polite developer big robot is
here to reintroduce British civility to
games culture it seems the best way to
do it is to replace the undead with
mustachioed automatons in top hats and
thus you have sir you are being hunted
or Madame you are being hunted if you so
prefer with 1999 you're buying an
in-progress single-player wilderness
survival game in which the procedurally
generated wilderness is the English
countryside and you eat haggis and
Christmas puddings when you're feeling
peckish this early access gem layers on
the charm but it's no less dramatic for
it your goal to collect the remains of a
machine that affords your escape your
problem robots are patrolling the
countryside and they're particularly
defensive of the area's you must
investigate more robots more
environments and more gameplay systems
are on the way but even now escaping a
hot air balloon searchlight is a tense
endeavor and the nearby chatter of
deadly robots can tie my stomach in
knots thankfully I always keep a meat
pie and a bottle of local stout on me
for comfort
now lest you go away thinking that steam
early access is only filled with fantasy
games beyond the realm of human
experience Andy Bauman is here to tell
you about assetto corsa now racing
high-end cars is pretty far beyond my
human experience but not as far beyond
it as being hunted by robots or having
my planet destroyed I hope
if you're saving your skrill for a steam
box and by passing an xbox one you may
feel a twinge of regret if you're
interested in car games broom broom
there will be no way for you to
experience Forza 5 but hold on to your
four hundred and seventy dollars and one
cent because there is a game available
on Steam early access that not only
sounds kind of like Forza but has cars
in it too assetto corsa it's driving sim
in development it's actually pretty cool
it's it's blue book value is 39 99
that's a car Joe currently there aren't
too many cars but there are some
recognizable whips like the Pagani Zonda
and the Ferrari 458 so far you can only
do hot laps time attacks and drag races
on the limited track selection but it
does have customizable realism settings
you can really test your abilities
around every turn on the most simulation
II of settings there isn't a rewind
function so you really have to be
cautious much like the steam early
access refund policy there are none so
know that this isn't the fully equipped
coop before you drive it off a lot it
does show some promise however and the
graphics are okay
and would you believe it folks
gamespot's steam early access week has
come to an end on behalf of myself and
my fellow game spotters I want to thank
you for tuning in joining the discussion
and sharing these videos with your
friends I'll be really interested to see
what games you're still talking about
now that we're through so chime in below
and have a great weekend